a recession is when your neighbor loses
his job
a depression is when you lose your job
and recovery is when joe biden loses his
job
because every minute that this
administration goes on
you are getting poorer inflation is
through the roof wages are stagnating
which may explain why rural democrats
are running away from their party
affiliation
and why the establishment media are
furious
at the daily wire for telling you the
truth i'm michael knowles is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from lawn mower man
who says it's easier to fool people than
it is to convince them that they've been
fooled a quote attributed to mark twain
this is true because
to convince someone that they have been
fooled you have to weaken their pride
and you have to get them to admit that
they got something wrong
whereas to fool people you don't need to
do any of that you can actually appeal
to their pride which is why
so many people get duped but you can't
dupe all the people all the time as as
we're
learning right now and the the most
tangible
uh way to see this is with the inflation
joe biden says oh things are getting
better we're recovering more america's
opening up again but everything's
way way more expensive and when
inflation is a concern
you might want to invest in physical
gold acre gold will let you start
investing in physical gold
for as little as 30 michael you liar
don't lie to me
like all the establishment media have
been lying to me i'm not lying to you
but michael you say physical gold costs
more than 30
i know it does acre has figured out an
ingenious way
for you to start investing in physical
gold and the way is this you subscribe
to their gold bars you pay 30
a month when your gold stash reaches the
price of their gold bars
they will discreetly ship acre gold to
your door
and then you're good you've got a
physical asset that tends to be a very
good hedge
on inflation which is a very very big
concern right now
i have really enjoyed investing in
physical precious metals and i really
enjoy investing in acre gold
visit getacregold.com knowles today
start investing in physical gold make
sure you go to that url
because acre is giving away a gold bar
if you want to win that gold bar
then you've got to tweet why you should
be the recipient just post it out there
and you got to mention at get underscore
acre that is getacregle.com
knowles and thank you aker gold for
supporting the show
joe biden's inflation we call it bite
inflation this from a washington post
reporter heather long
just pointing out yesterday here is a
year-over-year
change in prices for car rentals
87.7 percent up
used cars 45.2 percent up laundry
machines almost 30
up airfare about 25 up
which i've noticed having been on the
road for the past few days it's uh those
things are way up
uh moving expenses it's like when you
need to flee new salinas california is
over 17
up hotels about 17 up furniture 8.6
up i've noticed that too bacon even just
bacon one of the
great constellations of life eight point
four percent off
tvs seven point six percent fruit a
little over seven percent shoes six and
a half percent
fresh fish very difficult for us
catholics on fridays
six point four percent up new cars over
five percent up milk five point six
percent up
rent two point three percent up and gas
here's the killer
with bite inflation in full swing gas is
up
forty five point one percent
now the inflation wouldn't matter if
wages were rising
as well are your wages up forty five
percent
no are your wages up five percent no are
your wages up two and a half percent no
they're not
wages have not gained since biden became
president during the trump
administration
you had the first real wage gains
in a very very long time and under biden
that has completely stalled out
so obviously the biden administration
trying to downplay all of this
they told us do you remember on the
fourth of july they said you better
thank joe biden this year
oh yeah things are so much better under
joe biden
the cost of a fourth of july barbecue is
down
it's down 16 so when you're
buying your hot dogs and your hamburgers
and your beer and your fireworks and
your iced tea
and your lawn chairs don't don't worry
actually celebrate you've saved
16 percent and then you got in your car
and spent 45
more on gasoline or not 60 you saved 16
cents and then you
you spent 45 percent more on gasoline
that's not great
obviously the conservative policies are
working way
way better here the proof of the pudding
is in the tasting because
from the liberal establishment you are
not going to hear
that things are worse under
joe biden you're going to occasionally a
reporter will go out there and and
that's not great that will not be echoed
throughout the press
but look at what the businesses are
doing disney is as woke a corporation as
they get
however disney is also moving 2 000 jobs
from california to florida why because
florida has a climate that's conducive
to business florida has a climate that's
conducive to our constitutional rights
florida lets people out in the open to
walk around and go to church and go to
their
jobs and go to school and just live and
california does not california is
actually locking down again even if
you're vaccinated
you've still got to wear the masks now
so disney might talk a good game on
wokeness
but when it comes down to brass tacks
they're going to move their jobs to
florida
wall street executives are moving their
jobs from new york to florida
goldman sachs among among other firms
are now looking
at moving offices to the sunshine state
you notice with this with desantis too
everyone will say desantis is doing a
bad job
he's awful we can't trust the numbers
he's terrible cuomo's so much better
but the behavior shows what they really
think
this is why the establishment media are
so furious at us there is an art this is
my favorite article
this is truly my favorite article that i
have seen in months it's from npr
headline outrage as a business model
how ben shapiro is using facebook to
build an empire i'll read you just the
first
paragraph or so here in 2021 ben shapiro
rules facebook
the conservative podcast host and
author's personal facebook page has more
followers than the washington post
and he drives an engagement machine
unparalleled by anything else on the
world's biggest social networking site
an npr analysis of social media data
found that over the past year stories
published by the site shapiro found in
the daily wire
received more likes shares and comments
on facebook than
any other news publisher by a wide
margin
even legacy news organizations that have
broken major stories or produced
groundbreaking
investigative work don't come anywhere
close
i'd like to translate this article for
you if you want if you want to know
the subtext of this article it's this
headline wow
first paragraph wow
no the daily wire is good at what they
do
people want to read it uh they don't
trust us anymore but they do trust
shapiro and knowles enclave and boring
and walsh
i love it so first of all
they're seeding to us that we are way
better at
talking to people than they are and they
they grant to us that people
are more inclined to believe what we
have to say than what they have to say
and to engage in
what we're talking about than what what
they're talking about but here's what
they say it's outrage
and they go on and they cite a bunch of
lib professors and things like that and
they say
they're monetizing outrage and hate and
anger so first of all we don't i think i
actually think this is a
rather reasonable balanced program you
know we make fun of them obviously but
we tell you exactly what point of view
we're coming from
i like to think that we also present the
best arguments from the other side and
then explain why they're
stupid arguments but compared to cnn
compared to msnbc
compared to the new york times i think
we do way more of that i think we are
way more fair
than any of those guys are and by the
way they generally speaking won't even
come out
with their biases right cnn says facts
first
facts we're a banana we're an apple
banana the new york times all the news
that's fit to print it's really all the
news that fits the narrative
they say oh i'm so depressed by this
it's terrible
are you telling me that cnn doesn't
focus on
outrage cnn for the trump presidency had
a covid death count that was constantly
going
you don't really see that quite so much
under the biden administration
cnn the new york times the washington
post would just make up stories they
would just make them up about donald
trump colluding with the
russkies remember that they would
sensationalize stories about donald
trump with prostitutes in moscow based
on
nothing completely made up to gin up
outrage daily wire has never done
anything like that
the daily wire does not monetize outrage
anywhere in the same stratosphere as the
new york times and cnn
and the washington post and npr
apparently
and and by the way when we do focus on
outrages
they are legitimate outrages not totally
cooked up contrived nonsense but npr
very upset
why is the daily wire successful is it
because we're so handsome
and so wonderful and so great i like to
think so but you know what you know what
i actually think it is and i say this
with no false modesty i think the reason
that the daily wire is doing better in
terms of engagement with real people
is because the establishment media blew
their credibility and they lied to the
people and they lied lied lie lied and
eventually the people stopped paying
attention
and then the daily wire has done our
best to get it right and you know
sometimes we get it wrong like everyone
sometimes gets it wrong
but we haven't just lied and pushed a
liberal establishment propaganda proved
a message
down your throats constantly and so
people respond well to
that certainly on the right but also in
the middle and even some people
who are on the left that's what i think
they're really they're not upset at ben
shapiro and they're not upset at the
rest of us at the daily wire
if they are it's misplaced they should
be upset with themselves for tarnishing
their own credibility
the proof of this thesis the proof that
i'm right about this
is that outside of the media in elected
politics democrats in rural areas
are not even acknowledging that they're
democrats anymore
which would make sense to me you know
that the old days
where the democratic party was more
moderate and patriotic are gone
okay we've got a very polarized time
right now if you want to remember the
good old days one thing i would suggest
paint your life i am so impressed with
paintyourlife.com
i can't believe it when i first heard
about them they decided to come onto the
podcast they said
it's very simple process you send in a
photo or multiple photos a world-class
artist will create an actual painting i
prefer
the oil paintings but there are other
kinds too from those photos
you get to work with them the whole way
you get to approve the proofs and
everything
and then you get it and i thought you
know i bet it's just not gonna be that
good so what did i do
the first time i tried it i gave one to
my stepbrother i said i wanted to see
because it wasn't any good then he would
have to put it on his wall
and then i got it and it was gorgeous it
was so incredibly impressive it was very
inexpensive so you know what i did for
the second one
that one went to me and i've got it
hanging in my living room it's just
so beautiful it can be of a loved one
of a favorite place of a pet it's just
anything you want at paintyourlife.com
there is no risk if you don't love the
final painting your money is refunded
guaranteed but you're going to love it
right now as a limited offer
you can get 20 off your painting that is
20
off and free shipping to get that
special offer text michael
to 64 000 that's m-i-c-h-a-e-l to 64 000
paint your life celebrate the moments
that matter most
terms apply available at paint your life
dot com slash terms text michael
to 64 000. the democratic party knows
that as a matter of
popularity right now it is losing okay
i don't think there's any any two ways
around that they might still win
elections and they might still dominate
the media
because they have they got rid of a lot
of election integrity measures and they
dominate the
institutions that exist but as a matter
of popularity i think they know they're
losing the proof of this is
democrats in rural areas are
running away from the democratic party
there was there are a number of
candidates in ohio and
elsewhere who in one minute two minute
even
three minute campaign ads will never
mention that they are democrats this
according to a
report from axios this is because
democrats in the house right
now have a very very thin majority
and the polling looks absolutely
devastating for them in 2022.
so people ask me i was actually just
speaking to a
congresswoman friend of mine here at
tpusa
i said how are you guys feeling about
2022. she said everyone
in congress everyone in politics thinks
that the republicans are going to crush
it in 2022.
now my only caveat to this is if we
don't resolve the election issues
the use of widespread mail-ins the
failure to clean up the voter rolls and
purge people who are not eligible to
vote
the motor voter laws of the ballot
harvesting and the list goes on and on
and on
then i'm not so sure that republicans
are going to do right in 2022.
i think in order to do really well in
2022 we need to be able to rely on the
integrity of our elections and
increasingly we can't do that
because last cycle the democrats got rid
of some of the most important election
integrity measures
and then this cycle republicans are
trying to put them back in place the
measures that we had in most places
even three years ago and republi and
democrats rather saying this is a return
to jim crow
this is awful they're trying to
federalize the elections to make
permanent
the radical changes they made with covet
as the excuse so that that kind of makes
me
worry however it just shows you
something we've been talking about for a
long time
which is the disparity between ordinary
americans
the people and the ruling class
this is a frequent rhetorical tool that
is used by both parties
you know where they they talk about the
elites and the
regular people but i i want to be clear
here i'm not just using some cheap
rhetorical
trick on issues that are very very
important the vast majority of americans
are on one side of the issue and the
ruling class is on the other
i look at immigration the vast majority
of americans
wants to reduce immigration the majority
of americans wants to reduce even legal
immigration but certainly when you get
to illegal immigration the number it
isn't even close
and yet the ruling class mostly
democrats but some
some republicans as well the chamber of
commerce type of republicans
they don't want to do anything about it
on the issue of voter id the vast
majority of americans support voter id
the ruling class does not support voter
id
there are a number of other issues like
this is a radical gender theory the vast
majority of americans don't want to cram
radical gender theory down everybody's
throats
the ruling class does on the critical
race theory stuff
the vast majority of americans don't
want this in their schools the ruling
class clearly does so there's a huge
disparity here
between the people and the elites who
control the institutions
and so i think they know that they're
losing as a matter of popularity the
only question is
have they rested enough power from the
american people that that will not
matter speaking of regimes that have
taken too much power from the people
cuba continues to find itself in turmoil
because the people are protesting the
communist regime that has existed there
for 60 years
and aoc refuses to go hard against the
regime
actually another washington post
reporter again every so often you'll get
one or two from wapo or new york times
or somewhere else
who report the news as they see it this
is not now the position
of the editorial boards of those papers
it's not not the opinion
this is not the strategy that is
generally pursued by the papers anymore
but still every once in a while you get
a good reporter
so a reporter from the washington post
said the quiet part out loud he said
that aoc
will not attack the communist regime
because broadly she agrees with it
we're just talking about how
progressives are really happy about all
of the things
in the infrastructure bill they are
really being led in many ways by the
progressive wing of their party and
the progressive wing of the democratic
party does not want to go hard
against cuba against some of the things
that
the castro regime may have been a part
of in part because there are some
democrats there are some progressives
who
agree with some of those things they
agree with universal health care they
agree with some of the programs that
were in place
in a more socialist kind of society
this is obviously true aoc in particular
identifies as a socialist
she identifies with the ideology of or
the very near ideology
of the dominant regime in cuba this is
true of a number of other
democrat members of congress and the
american left broadly
has never apologized for its support of
communism
its overt support of communism in the
papers and in the government
and in on the campaign trail
which went on for about 100 years the
american left has never apologized for
supporting the soviet union for instance
actually what they did is the last
election cycle as we saw they just
accused
the republicans of colluding with russia
the democrats colluded with russia for a
hundred years but
then they start accusing the republicans
of colluding with russia
colluding with russia were a problem
most prominent democrats from the 20th
century would be in prison
now aoc won't totally admit this
the the american left won't totally
admit it they'll just remain silent we
played those clips from bernie sanders
yesterday bernie sanders has been a huge
supporter
of the castro regime in cuba and of
communists elsewhere he did his
honeymoon in the soviet union
and he's just remained basically silent
on the cuba issue because he knows that
the reality of the situation is
contradicting his
crazy theories even beyond this very
abstract idea of communism and free
markets and things like that
look at what's going on on the ground
right now
around our country crime is going
through the roof
not just shootings not just murders
which are way way up in places like
chicago
but look over in dc just just
carjackings
are up and they're not up a little bit
you see those inflation numbers
and you say wow 87.7 up on car rentals
45 up on gas that's not just a little
bit well carjackings are up in dc not 5
not 10 they're up 74 year over year
there are people now who are calling for
bait cars to be placed to finally lure
some of these criminals in
uh they just had a press conference with
the police in dc
to figure out how to in any way impede
this
this huge spike in crime chief i want to
ask you real quick about the recent
card jackings why are you not using bait
cars to catch
carjackers we used one a couple years
ago and with your officer's health
actually caught
two suspects and prosecuted yeah i'm
glad you brought that point up uh the
over the last couple of hours uh over
the
yeah the last couple hours last 12 hours
we had a significant
uh spree of carja of robberies that have
occurred
across our city i'm happy to report uh
within the last hour
we've located the the vehicle we didn't
need a bait car uh to necessarily do
that we do deploy bait cars at times
most recently in the second district
they use it but we want to make sure
that the tactic uh certainly works for
the specific crime that we happen to be
targeting at that particular time
well now we didn't have to use a bait
car because the guy stole someone's car
so a lot we didn't have to do that we
want to make sure the tactics are
calibrated to the communities
and i i have great sympathy for this guy
because
the reason you've got 74 increase in
carjacking is the reason you've got 50
increase in shootings and murders in
chicago
it's not complicated it's not because of
just
natural fluxes organically it's because
the democrats spent well over a year
saying we need to abolish the police
and we need to defund the police and
then they actually did defund the police
in a lot of places
and then they threw a bunch of police
officers in prison for just doing their
jobs
and now cops are walking off the job and
cops are more timid
and the departments are underfunded
that's why that's why it's not
complicated folks
the genius egghead analysts at the new
york times and the washington post
they're going to blame all sorts they're
going to blame white supremacy they're
going to blame the patriarchy they're
going to probably blame trump they're
going to blame every
they're going to blame the abstract
fluxes of history but they're not going
to blame
what every ordinary american knows
namely if you incentivize crime
and you punish law enforcement you're
going to get more crime and you're going
to get less
law enforcement they're learning and i
suppose the american people always
sort of knew this but what the liberal
establishment i guess is seeing right
now
with the inflation with the crime with
the pushback against their policies is
that eventually
the bill comes due there is no such
thing as a free lunch
eventually you've got to pay so you
print money and you print money and you
print money and you give people a bunch
of money for free and you tell them to
stay in their homes and not to do
anything
you know what happens you get inflation
that's what happens
you get criminals burning down the
country for a year
and you punish the people who are trying
to stop them from doing that
and you let the ones who do that off the
hook you know what you're going to get
you're going to get more crime you're
going to get more people burning stuff
down you're getting
actually in america's hat right now in
canada you're getting more and more
churches being burned
to the ground and there's no enforcement
so you know what you're going to get
more of that
i do not support a view of politics that
is primarily
economic i'm with edmund burke the age
of chivalry has gone that if sophisters
economists and calculators have
succeeded it and the glory of europe is
extinguished forever
i don't want egghead pollen but there
were some basic economic lessons here
it's really just
basic lessons of human nature if you
want more of something incentivize it if
you want less of something
punish it carjackings way up
how about covid you notice places where
kovit is spiking
tend to have a lot of one group of
people
one group of people that are not
supposed to be in this country one group
of people who by definition are breaking
the laws
the illegal immigration problem this
show the illegal immigration problem
shows you what a farce the covid
lockdowns have been
because we are told that if we leave our
homes without 20 masks and 15
jabs of an experimental drug then we're
killing everybody
and yet we have already let
one million foreign nationals
very few of whom have been tested for
kovid into our country this year
so you can't go to school but you can
come from guatemala and just go anywhere
and we have no idea where you are
that is not serious that is going to
tarnish your credibility people are not
going to believe you anymore
and that ain't been shapiro's fault and
then at the daily wire's fault that is
the fault
of the liberal establishment you know
senator cruz is really really good on
this issue
and i have to wonder if it's because of
his very impressive beard
if you want that really gruff
texan manly cruise beard
well you know that doesn't just happen
okay you don't just wake up and say boom
there it is no
you've got to do it the right way
you need some beard oils you need some
soap you need some beard shears and
beard balm you need
beard supply if you're going to grow a
beard head on over to beersupply.com
for a limited time only you
can buy one beard oil product and get
another one
for free what a great deal head on over
to our friends at beardsupply.com today
order yourself two beard oils for the
price of one
you can mix and match different scents
or stock up on the old classic
their best seller winter number one oh
how rough how manly whatever you choose
make sure you choose
beard supply for a limited time only
right now go to beardsupply.com
and buy one beard oil get another one
free and then you can compare yourself
to that gruff texan ted cruz
now we've got a lot of news for you
the the irony i think maybe not the
irony i guess it's just the
coincidence it's probably the cause of
the article
the npr comes out and attacks us on the
very day
that we launched a direct challenger to
npr
which is called the morning wire hosted
by daily wire editor-in-chief
john bickley and and his co-host georgia
howe morning wire
very quickly we'll just give you the
facts we'll give you right in the
morning
the most important news developments set
your
news cycle for the day tell you what
matters
and why it matters go check it out right
now you can subscribe to morning wire on
apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play myspace sanga live
journal aol instant messenger anywhere
you get your podcasts
also ben shapiro's new book is hitting
bookshelves next tuesday july 27th
very very important that you order my
book speechless before
that happens and then you can pre-order
ben's book the authoritarian
moment which is really really important
because that will be my campaign slogan
in some years so make sure you get it
that way when i
run for office you can cut out the front
flap and you can put it on your t-shirt
and you can say knowles 2028
the authoritarian moment you can head on
over right now to get a signed copy of
ben's book at dailywire.com
ben you will be asked to type a question
in at checkout
that you want him to answer during his
live signing head on over dailywire.com
ben we'll be right back with a lot more
will hear from the establishment media
that there's a spike
in coronavirus cases in texas now
remember by the way
when texas ended its mass mandate many
months ago
we were told there's going to be a huge
spike in cases in deaths
beto o'rourke said this will be a death
sentence for texans
and then that didn't happen texas was
actually doing better than anybody
so in the period of time where you would
have expected kova to spike it didn't
happen
but now kovit apparently is spiking in
texas
senator cruz the senator from texas
has a crazy wild conspiracy theory on
what that might be that the
establishment media doesn't want to tell
you
you're packing children into cages with
a lot of them having coveted and more of
them getting covered
and the biden administration is ignoring
the law and releasing into our
communities
people that have coveted most of whom
are coming across this border who are
not vaccinated and
white right now biden is talking about
ending title 42
which is the health protection that says
we're not going to release people
carrying
potentially communicable diseases so yes
you better believe the rising covet
rates are due
in significant part to illegal aliens
that the bible administration is
releasing in texas
that have coven rates seven times higher
than the u.s population
and we need to stop being bone-headed
and ignoring the science which is what
the bind administration is doing
well of course that's true i mean if if
you've got coveted cases spiking
a few weeks after you had um
188 000 illegal aliens pour across the
border these are insane record numbers
we're halfway through the year and
you've had a million illegal aliens come
in already but you had a huge huge spike
in june and then a few weeks later you
get a spike in covey cases
no surprise this shows you though that
the covid madness and the vaccine
madness and the lockdowns and the delta
and the lambda and the phi beta kappa
and
the mass mandates are
less about the virus less about the
public health
and much more about the imposition of
the rules
this was an observation that angelo
cotavilla made about political
correctness
angelo from the claremont institute he
said that political correctness is less
about the words that you need to use
and more about the imposition of the
words and who gets to impose
those words the same thing is true of
covid if if kovid were really the
greatest threat in the entire world that
everyone tells us it is
the liberal establishment that's pushing
that narrative would shut down the
border
but they're not shutting down the border
they're actually encouraging people to
come
because kovid is not nearly as great a
risk as they pretend that it is
the the only uh really grave risk it
poses at the national level
is to our traditional political order
but dr fauci de fouchi is
do you know what's so funny i have to
take a pause here i was at tpusa
yesterday
charlie kirk really knows how to put on
a great show because this was
thousands and thousands of young
conservatives packed into the room
you walk out it's pyrotechnics and it's
really an
impressive show and so i give my speech
you can catch that speech online
and then we're taking questions from the
audience and one of the questions was
michael can you do it after voucher
impression so i rattled off a bit of a
fouchy impression got a standing ovation
and i thought this is the only time
ever that conservatives are going to
give a standing ovation to dr fauci
because they're not appointing dr fauci
they're applauding
us making fun of dr fauci because the
man has has just made himself into a
joke
into a punch line into a farce the way
that he
changes his directives by the hour
not because the science has changed but
because the politics has changed
the way that he is so sanctimonious the
way that he is so fear-mongering the way
that he is has
been caught in in open lies
to us well now dr fauci is going out
there
and he is he is assenting to the idea
that if
fox news that's the stand-in for
conservative media if fox news existed
many many moons ago why we wouldn't
never would have eradicated smallpox
do you think we could have eradicated
polio or defeated the measles
uh if you had uh fox news night after
night uh
warning people about these uh vaccine
uh issues that are just uh you know bunk
well that is a very good point jim if
you look at the extraordinary historic
success in eradicating smallpox
and eliminating polio from most of the
world and we're on the brink
of eradicating polio if we had had the
pushback
for vaccines the way we're seeing on
certain media
i don't think it would have been
possible at all to not only eradicate
smallpox we probably would still have
smallpox and we probably would still
have
polio in this country if we had the kind
of
false information that's being spread
now if we had that back
decades ago i would be certain that we'd
still have polio in this country
the most prominent spreader of false
information in the united states right
now is dr fauci
don't wear the mask wear the mask we'll
we won't get a vaccine we got a vaccine
it won't be that effective it's very
effective and up and down and left and
right and wear the mask sheep
wear the mask what dr fauci says and he
wants to keep sort of more neutral tones
so he lets acosta do this dirty work for
him
right you get you get the liberal news
anchor who says
if we had fox news do you think that
would have that would have
uh permitted us to eradicate bad
diseases will
uh no i don't and and actually even
worse diseases we'd probably still have
so if ouchie won't name fox news voucher
talks about misinformation
which he's using as a synonym for fox
news which he's using as a symbol of all
of the conservative media
but you know what people believe the
conservative media
most notably of all they believe the
daily wire and they engage with the
daily wire
not because we're such special guys i
like to think we're very special guys
but because the other outlets have
become
themselves and have lied and so now
they're talk they're looking to us
and fauci is very upset about that well
fauci if you wanted people to listen to
you
you know what you could have done not
lied to them for a year
15 days to slow this spread
oh those stupid idiots they those people
wearing the masks
they think 15 and then what's he doing
15 months later he's just 15 more days
believe old dr
why won't they believe me anymore
because you lie to them that's why
that's why they don't believe you
the liberal establishment does not have
a ton of credibility on biology at the
moment actually
the international olympic committee has
just made a final decision on whether or
not
giant hulking dudes should be permitted
to compete against women
at tests of brute strength
in an earlier time this would not have
been a difficult question
but now it is a difficult question so
there is a new zealand weightlifter
fellow by the name of laurel hubbard i
don't i don't know his real name but he
now
goes by laurel and he
was a male weight lifter who competed
against other men and he didn't do very
well there
and then he transitioned to make himself
look more like a woman
now he competes against women and he
beats them all the time so the question
was
is this fella permitted to to compete
against women
the ioc says absolutely
he became the first transgender woman
also known as a man to qualify for the
olympics at 43 years old
he qualified in the 87 kilogram category
i don't know how much that is because
i'm an american and i use real
measurements but
everything's trans now you know the
genders the weight measurements
uh he already received support about
competing as a woman
in the competitions but the president of
the ioc
reiterated this gave a final decision on
saturday
so what that means is the women's
weightlifting competition
doesn't mean anything anymore because if
a woman's weightlifting competition
is going to mean anything it has to be
for women so if men can compete in that
it's no longer the women's weightlifting
competition
and the egghead geniuses
all the g or benevolent bettors they all
are applauding this there's about seven
of those people in the country
no it's more than that but there aren't
very many of them whereas the majority
of
not just the american people but the
majority of the people in new zealand
the majority of people around the world
are looking at this
not just with their eyebrows cocked but
looking at this like
the president of the ioc and every other
liberal egghead whose pro-transgenderism
has lost their minds
because they obviously have lost their
minds
no one believes this stuff and yet
because the
elites just by definition i guess have
this sort of power because the radicals
have attained positions of power
they can push it through even over the
objections of the majority of people
and this logic of transgenderism is
leading to something that is
really to my mind absolutely disgusting
this is leading to calls among prominent
senate democrats
to force women to register for the draft
this story is not getting a lot of
coverage politico did
did just report on it though
senate democrats are proposing a
sweeping rewrite of the military draft
laws
to require women to register for the
selective service system
according to a draft a draft of the
report authored by senate armed services
chairman jack
reed which was obtained by politico
this would be attached to the national
defense authorization act a defense
policy bill that is one of the few
pieces
that is considered a must-pass by
congress so they're going to try to ram
it in
to some legislation that congress is
just going to have to pass
so that they can get this through
i do not want to live in a country that
requires women to fight our wars for us
i don't want to live in that country
it's just wrong
now i see how we got to this point
a lot of people are going to say well
this is just too far or this is crazy or
this is but
no this is the logic of the last 50
years
the logic of second wave feminism or i'm
sorry the premise of second wave
feminism
is that women and men are basically the
same sure they look a little different
but hey a woman needs a man like a fish
needs a bicycle as gloria steinem said
the differences between men and women
are purely superficial women can do
anything men can do
and how dare you say otherwise well okay
if that's true if men and women are
basically
exactly the same then
surely the homosexual rights movement as
it was once called
is gonna go through no well of course
because men and women are exactly the
same
surely the redefinition of marriage
which was
the apotheosis of that movement has to
go through because men and women are
exactly the same so if if men and women
are the same
then your argument that marriage is the
union between one man and one woman
falls apart
these men and women are the same so then
i guess it could be the union of one man
and one man or one woman and one woman
and if that's true then the logic of
transgenderism has to hold
because if men and women are basically
the same then bruce jenner certainly can
become caitlyn
because those differences are just
superficial get a little nip tuck here
throw on some stilettos and a little bit
of lipstick and there you have it
bruce's caitlyn and frankly
he didn't even need to do that he could
have just said he's a woman as
as many people do now and that would
have been perfectly fine
and if men and women are exactly the
same then of course
women need to register for the draft
it would be unfair it would be unjust if
only men registered for selective
service and the problem with all of that
is
it's all false it's based on a false
premise
men and women are different this is the
fundamental distinction in human nature
men and women are not identical they are
complementary
they go together like love and marriage
like horse and carriage
you can't have one without the other in
in society
so you're going to hear two arguments on
this
from the right you're going to hear
i i'm just talking about people who
oppose women
registering for the draft you're going
to hear two kinds of arguments
one is the egghead arguments they're
going to tell you well actually you know
if you look at certain uh statistics and
if you look at um the levels of
testosterone and the way that
the bones and the this and the
development then actually women
are not quite suited for the draft and
blah blah blah
fine you know i'm willing to take any
argument that persuades anybody but that
to me is not the real argument
i don't even care if some other egghead
on the other side could prove that women
actually
do have the same bone density and the
same kind of muscle mass and actually
they're just as competent in the field
and that
i don't care i don't want to live in
that country going back to the edmund
burke quote
when he lamented during the french
revolution that the age of chivalry is
gone
and that of sophisters economists and
calculators has succeeded at the glory
of europe as extinguished forever
i don't want to live in the world of
sophisters economists and calculators
i don't care if you can prove to me that
by measuring testosterone
and bone density or any other physical
feature that men and women are very very
similar
men and women are different and a
country
that sends its women to fight its wars
is an ugly unchivalrous
uncivilized country i want to live in a
country
where men go fight the wars to protect
the women
where we have a real complementary
complementarity of the sexes where we
actually
work together and care for one another
and we don't just all pretend
that we're all exactly the same
speaking of castration just talking
about
men pretending to be women now we can
talk about men who have been
emasculated in in more subtle ways
prince harry prince harry is now set to
write
a memoir about his decision to be led
around on a leash by his wife
very sad for poor harry he will release
a quote
holy truthful memoir about his life in
the royal family
and his mexit escape to the united
states with
meghan markle this according to the new
york post's page six
which says that prince harry's
autobiography first draft of which is
nearly complete
is expected to be explosive
and that he will be retelling his life
story quote
not as the prince i was born but as the
man i have become
so pathetic so pathetic so
womanish not womanly when a woman
behaves like a woman that's womanly when
a man behaves like a woman
that's woman-ish is nothing sacred
anymore why is he doing this
he said that he was leaving the royal
family to live a private life
and we all knew that was ridiculous we
all knew that
meghan markle who has begged for
attention
her entire life and who was an actress
and who
sought after and married a prince and
then she didn't like having to
actually do things and and fulfill
duties and obligations so then she
made a bigger spectacle of herself by
pulling the prince away from his family
and now she still
takes every opportunity to go on oprah
and to make a big deal about herself
obviously they don't want to live a
private life they want to live a very
public life
without any duty and without any
obligation without any loyalty
to their country to their
family to the british people
and so now he's writing a tell-all to
drag the attention party on a little bit
longer and to trash his family this is
really
ugly stuff really really ugly stuff
but it's a symbol of broader political
decay
the reason that the the revolutionaries
in our culture the radicals
always want to go after the families
because the family is the fundamental
political institution
if you can upend that you can upend
everything that has successfully
happened in the united kingdom hope it
doesn't happen here
but speaking of men being led astray by
women and speaking of the international
olympic committee
they are actually doing one thing that
is pretty conservative
one thing that is pretty virtuous the
olympic committee has decided
that the olympians are not going to get
regular beds
when they go to olympic village they are
going to sleep on beds
made of cardboard why would they be
doing this they're doing this because
every year the olympians
have a ton of sex with each other and
they
have there's always a story about how
they've run out of condoms within a few
days
there's always a story about how
venereal disease is running rampant
and i get why you've got a bunch of
young people who are extremely hot and
extremely athletic
being brought together from all over the
world in this weird sort of summer camp
and that sort of thing is just going to
happen especially in a culture that has
pretty loose loose rules about this
stuff
so the olympic committee doesn't want
this to happen especially with covet 19.
forget about syphilis forget about
chlamydia they're worried about covet
19.
so they're putting them on cardboard
beds which are quote
allegedly designed to collapse under the
weight of fornicators
to discourage sex among amid coveted
19. they've got 18 000 of these
cardboard beds
you know this is actually something that
we can learn from we all
very often we spend our time trashing
the
international organizations on this show
that enforce the dominant liberal regime
but this is something actually we might
be able to learn from maybe they should
put these in college dorms
you know nice cardboard beds at the
minute you get two people on them
they collapse under the weight of that
that might be one good way to encourage
better and better behavior than people
engage in there
speaking of fornication too i have to
get to this story
there is evidence from that that peter
schweitzer who's a very good
conservative investigative journalist
that he has discovered
going back to an older new york post
story regarding hunter biden's laptop
that hunter biden was getting all these
sweetheart deals and committing all
sorts of crimes
there was the allegation based on hunter
biden's messages
that joe biden benefited directly from
that now peter schweitzer
says he has nailed down evidence that
shows
joe biden directly benefited from hunter
biden's corruption overseas
if you remember the bidens from the
beginning have lied and shifted the goal
posts at first remember
they said no there are no foreign deals
with the chinese that's all fake news
but then when it turned out that of
course those deals were real we showed
that they were real
they said well you know joe biden had no
knowledge of those deals when we showed
that joe biden had knowledge of those
deals it shifted to will he never
discussed it with his son
then when we showed that he discussed it
with his son they shifted to well he
never
directly benefit uh what we see from the
hunter by the laptop
and we do have a copy by the way here at
gai
of the laptop and all the files it
confirms that joe biden was a direct
beneficiary
we're in the middle of the investigation
now but by the end of the year
it will be completed and and it will it
will take on
a far more sinister tone that it has
even now in terms of what it says about
the biden family and the vulnerabilities
of the biden family
uh it's that bad so this is pretty
explosive stuff
it if it were just about any other
journalist
on the right who does these sorts of
things i would say ah i don't know i'm
gonna hold off i'm not totally
totally bought into that yet but
schweitzer is pretty good and so if he
if he says he's got the goods
then we will await that i'm not
surprised at all the biden family
has been a machine family now for a long
time i mean this guy's been an
institution in the democratic party for
50 years
there's been a lot of evidence of shady
deals he survived in washington a very
long time
so not surprised to see that sort of
thing speaking of foreign policy we
don't have time to get to it today
but i have to mention at least that
general petraeus
is now criticizing the quote-unquote
hasty decision
to withdraw from afghanistan we've been
in afghanistan now for 20 years
but this is considered hasty this is
this is a war that the american people
do not want to be fighting anymore we
don't know what the purpose of this war
is
we we've been told lots of different
things about the purpose of this war and
it's just not
it's just not working out is it just
more evidence that on this front on the
inflation front on the media front on
all of this
eventually the bill is going to come due
okay and if you
if you mislead the people and if you
stonewall the people and if you gaslight
the people
for long enough they're going to stop
believing you they're going to turn to
other people that's not the fault of
those other people like those of us here
at
daily wire that's not the fault of the
people themselves
that's your fault for lying and now
you've got to pay the price i'm michael
knowles is the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show the media and
politicians break out the coveted panic
but do the stats justify it plus
joe biden is unwilling to accept the
consequences of his own economic agenda
that's today on the bench bureau shall
give it a listen